the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
good afternoon people
we begin this afternoon our if I if I'm
right about this I think I am as the
syllabus shows that this is the last
American film we'll be looking at in the
term so we're sort of finishing the
Central American phase of our course
with tonight's film Robert Altman's
McCabe and mrs. Miller and I want to use
today's lecture this afternoon's lecture
to contextualize that moment of the
early 70s the late 60s and early 70s in
American film history and to try to draw
out some of the implications of the
astonishing transformation that overtook
American film in this in this period
we've been talking about this topic in
different ways all semester so by now I
think the narrative that I've been
implicitly following in the course
should already be overt for all of you
the film we're going to see tonight
Robert Altman's McCabe and mrs. Miller
is a can be understood as a as a
particularly clear example of the kind
of transformation an even subversion
that becomes a dominant note of American
moviemaking in the 1970s and part of the
lecture today will be devoted to
speculating about why that
transformation why those forms of
subversion occurred and of course if
you've been paying attention in the
course you know the answer already and
it's the answer that's already embedded
in the lecture outline a new form of
what work what I've been calling
consensus narrative emerges by really
decisively by the end but by the middle
and end of the 1960s and into the 1970s
it's a period that takes time but
essentially television supplants the
movies as the central story system of
the society not that movies become
trivial or unimportant but they begin to
occupy a new niche in the media ecology
of the country and I'll return to this
matter briefly you know in a few moments
but let me begin by by clarifying
something about the importance of the
presence in our
syllabus of McCabe and mrs. Miller and
more generally the prominence we've
given in our course to the seanrid the
Western film so I ask you to remember
the sorts of things we were saying about
genre forms generally about the aptness
even when one might think of as the
economic necessity of genre forms in a
for a system that is based on the
principle of mass production and I also
want to suggest you that the particular
forms of genre story the particular kind
of story that is told in a particular
society and certainly the ones that are
told in the generic forms that are
chosen by American society are going to
very powerfully reflect aspects of the
culture and we made a special emphasis
on the importance in our previous
classes of to particular genres that
emerge in with great decisiveness in the
sound era both identified by some
scholars as America's most distinctive
contribution to world cinema one form
was the screwball comedy and the
elaborations on comedy that developed
through the 30s and 1940s and the second
form the second distinctive American
contribution to film as some scholars
have said is the Western we've talked a
bit about the nature of the Western and
how the Western as a form is rooted in
the assumptions and preoccupations of
American culture how it grows out of a
an historical actuality the period the
period roughly from 1860 to 1890 when
the Civil War occurred when the range
war to occur occur when the range Wars
occurred when the great when the great
gold discoveries were made at the great
gold row at the California Gold Rush the
laying of the Transcontinental Railroad
all of these historical realities then
become mythic elements in the founding
story that becomes the epic the epic
account of American identity the
American account of the epic account of
America's founding and I've suggested
that the creation of that mythology
expressed so powerfully and complexly
often
and disturbingly - because there's a
racism as we've said in imperialism
implicit in certain aspects of the
Western mythology that that fundamental
energy of the of the of the genre as
we've suggested is not only deeply
rooted in American culture and grows out
of the particular individualistic
preoccupations of American culture as we
suggested last time but also then
becomes a particularly dramatic instance
of what we might say the movies as a
whole have been in American society or
were in American society until the
advent of television and that is each
genre can bend the western genre
especially can be understood as a kind
of small and version of the larger
processes that that operate in this
consensus system and if you recall the
kinds of things we were suggesting last
week about the evolution of the Western
what what we were confronting in a
certain sense was the way in which this
astonishingly protein shift changing
mythology can be altered depending on
the preoccupations of the society that
wants to mobilize the mythology another
way of putting this is to say the
mythology like the larger culture is
never fixed it's always in process right
so that when one Western appears a kind
of conversation is going on with all
previous westerns and and and maybe with
other forms of discourse as well about
the central preoccupations that are part
of the West and I just want to remind
you of the sort of historical scheme
that I sketched in last time about the
Western so you can recognize the point
at which McCabe and mrs. Miller sort of
fits our picture right we remember that
I suggested in some degree that that
when the Western as a form emerges after
the after the 30s when it's mainly a
sort of novelty item which has singing
Cowboys in it and that sort of thing
when the classic Western emerges in 1939
with John Ford's film the what's the
name of the film stagecoach the first
film that a Ford filmed in Monument
Valley
when the age of the so-called classical
age of the Western begins in nineteen in
the 1940s we suggest I suggested in that
lecture that that that the westerns of
that period had a kind of imperial
dimension that those were the westerns
that most decisively and fully
celebrated the the white settlers idea
of the manifest destiny of the American
experiment which was much translated of
course in to exterminate the Indians the
Indians are sort of in the way the
westward expansion of the United States
was in many ways clearly an imperial and
even a racist project but in the period
of the 1940s the disturbing elements of
the mythology were suppressed or ignored
even though they were implicit why would
that have been well one reason was
America itself was that war in the 1940s
and the Western was a particularly
appropriate it's not the only vehicle
but it was one of the vehicles in which
Imperial ideas of American destiny and
American and and American identity would
be would be would be articulated or
dramatized and I suggested that as as
the war event meant that in the period
of the 1950's the the this Western form
began to complicate itself that it was
that it became less Imperial and that
there are many films of the 19 of
Western films of the 1950's that
actually reflect many of the domestic
concerns of that era the generation gap
the discontent of young people growing
up into a society that seemed to have no
work for them this is the early 1950s
and in craz the decade goes on and and
and leads into the 1960s an increasing
awareness of racial turmoil in the
United States so westerns begin to be
partly about juvenile delinquency or
about social problems always filtered of
course through the historical lens of
the Western and I suggested to you that
the great John Ford classic Western that
we saw last week the searchers had
already in the in the late 50s had
already begin to incorporate certain
kinds of subvert the certain certain
kinds of subversive questions so so the
50s is a time when the Western begins to
show so shows
social problems there's a kind of inward
turning in which the psychological
problems of characters become important
in a new way and and then in the 60s
this questioning of the genre proceeds
and expands even more even more fully
and as we suggested there are a series
of films of a sixty of westerns in the
60s that even more substantially than
The Searchers begin to sort of raise
doubts about some of the most
fundamental questions of the Western and
and of course as the decade wears on
there are increasing encouragment s-- or
incitements from the larger culture from
the social history of the larger culture
to make the the the western genre begin
to question itself and what are those
things that begin to happen as the 60s
wears on they were embedded in the 50s
what they become more much more serious
the first is racial turmoil right the
civil rights movement becomes more and
more militant through the 1960s and the
so they're there there is real conflict
in the society really very powerfully
what's a second and and and that racial
turmoil becomes more and more militant
more and more polarizing as the decade
goes on but what's the other great
terrible fact of the 1960's that
explains why American society was so
divided and so uncertain of itself the
Vietnam War of course right by the end
of the decade America's deeply immersed
in Vietnam the college-age generation is
to alienate it from its from its from
its elders there are demonstrations on
campuses in 1967-68 right and then in
1968 two really horrific assassinations
occurred that helped mark the 1960s as a
decisively disturbed time in American
history who who who are the two great
figures who died you know who are
assassinated in in 1968 one is
Martin Luther King most the the great
hero of a peaceful Gandy like civil
rights movement is assassinated and that
gives even stronger impetus to the more
militant of arguments for civil rights
that were month at that that unlike dr.
King's position did not so eagerly
embrace non-violence so the combination
of the Vietnam War and the civil rights
movement combining together create
creating a tremendous turmoil in the in
American society and there are many film
historians who would say that the
totally subversive genre films the
auntie Jean er films that emerge in the
1970s of which the most decisive example
you know our course is McCabe and mrs.
Miller so it completes our argument
right there many who would say that a
sufficient explanation for the
subversion of of the genre for the fact
that the westerns that that the westerns
of the 70s and at some of the westerns
of the 70s and Beyond in some sense
could be identified as anti Western so
hostile are they so hostile are they to
the basic assumptions of their of their
ancestors so much they turn the heroic
values of their ancestors on their head
and you'll and you'll see a wonderfully
decisive example of this in tonight's
film so there's some social and film
historians who would say well the
difficulties in the outer society the
war the civil rights movement the the
polarization of the culture is
sufficient to explain why these genres
and especially this centrally American
genre of the Western would suddenly sort
of turn on itself and stand and attack
what it had previously celebrated the
notions of notions of individualistic
achievement notions of violent
masculinity one of the best books on the
Old West and about the on the western
film has the wonderful title
regeneration through violence
regeneration through violence and it
does describe what the classic Western
seems to believe that that that and it's
it's actually a scary idea you might
think about how often this notion has
been translated into sort of foreign
policy behavior by the United States
as again reinforcing the importance of
these of these mythologies but but the
social history of the country is not
really sufficient fully to explain why
the movies would become so subversive
and what's the answer
I mean you can Munir in number three
right it has to do with the new
consensus medium so let me try to make
these arguments in a slightly more
systematic way and first by talking more
concretely about the ways in which the
movies were different in the 1970s we
wherever we look at central elements of
the movies we can see a profound change
in atmosphere in tone and feel the first
if we think if we think about the sort
of characteristic actors or acting
styles of the period we can be and
especially the characteristic stars and
contrast them to the great stars of the
studio era we can get a feel for how
much more subversive problematic ironic
anti-heroic this new period in American
film is but there are many many people
who would actually say that this moment
in American film is actually one of the
and I think I might say this is one is
one of the it's a moment of great
artistic achievements whatever we would
say about the early 70s and oh maybe the
whole decade of the 70s we we could call
it a moment or a period of profound
transition a great artistic achievement
but also but an achievement gotten that
a profound cost a fundamental
irreversible shift in the relation of
American movies to their audience okay
so that's the basic idea but what did
this shift look like what did it feel
like well I suggested that it's grungy
or more ironic more anti more much
deeply anti-heroic and one way I can
capture this is by taking a scene from
one of the characteristic really
defining actors of the 1970s of the of
the what we might call the post
consensus era the post Hollywood era
Jack Nicholson well I want to show you
what is in some sense his signature
scene and even people who haven't seen
five Easy Pieces where this fragment
comes from Noah
this scene what I want to propose to you
as you look at the seniors think about
Jack Nicholson's behavior in this scene
and ask yourself is it possible to
imagine one of the classic much more
dignified heroes of the male
protagonists movie stars from an earlier
era behaving in the same way could we
imagine John Wayne behaving this way or
could we imagine Jimmy Stewart behaving
this way or Henry Fonda behavior and of
course the answer I'm sure as you'll
recognize is no here is the scene then
from five Easy Pieces some people would
call it Jack Nicholson's signature
moment what's on the menu you can have a
number two a plain omelet it comes with
cottage fries and rolls I have made up
my mind I'd like a plain omelet no
potatoes on the plate a cup of coffee
and a side order of wheat toast I'm
sorry we don't have any side orders of
toast I'll give you our English muffin
or a coffee roll what do you mean you
don't make side orders of toast you make
sandwiches don't you would you like to
talk to the manager hey Mac shut up
you've got bread and a toaster of some
kind I don't make the rules okay I'll
make it as easy for you as I can
I'd like an omelet plain and a chicken
salad sandwich on wheat toast no
mayonnaise no butter no lettuce and a
cup of coffee number two chicken sauce
and Ola butter the lettuce the
mayonnaise and a cup of coffee anything
else yeah now all you have to do is hold
the chicken bring me the toast give me a
check for the chicken salad sandwich and
you haven't broken any rules you want me
to hold the chicken huh I want you to
hold it between your knees
you see that sign sir yes you all have
to leave I'm not taking any more of your
smartness and sarcasm you see this sign
you've seen Nicholson in far more
frenetic moments in let's say the Batman
movie right but the the essence of the
Nicholson character that's sort of he's
actually calmer and nicer there than he
normally is he has his persona has not
been fully established at this early
stage in his career but you can feel the
energy there and and the the the
hostility to it took to rule I mean I
think we're supposed to be on Nicholson
side in that film but when he knocks
that stuff off the table he's doing
something that we would never that we
would never imagine a classic Hollywood
hero to have done and I don't want to
put a too great of an emphasis on a
single scene but if you think about
Nicholson's incarnations after that
movie you'll understand how decisively
and fully a new kind of actor has a has
emerged in the 1970s and you might talk
about some of the other about some of
the other actors that you can do the
other sheet there Greg about some of the
other actors that emerge in this period
Warren Beatty
Elliott Gould Dustin Hoffman Robert De
Niro um
fewer female stars emerge in this period
but they're important and but some of
them did begin their careers around this
time and had and they also they even the
actresses standing us in the same sort
of ayran izing and and anti-heroic
relation to their ancestors as the male
actors do we might think about julie
christie who is the co-star of tonight's
film and McCabe and mrs. Miller or Jane
Fonda or or or or the actress Faye
Dunaway who does such a brilliant job in
the characteristic early 70s film
Chinatown and each of these performers
has as I suggested as I've suggested a
sort of grungy ionized non hero
relationship to the to the iconic
figures of the hollywood past and this
something of the same thing is true
about the kinds of directors and the
kinds of films that emerge in this
period as well it's the period in which
some directors who then became dominant
figures over the next thirty years
Martin Scorsese Roman Polanski Alan J
Pakula Francis Ford Coppola Sam
Peckinpah Altman himself Stanley Kubrick
all of these really distinctive tourist
directors emerge decisively in this
period and again the the films that they
make have a kind of personal stamp that
would not have been possible in the
studio era so the even though film and
of course when I've left out of the
equation and talking about the
transformation of American movies is the
reminder that it was in the period from
1950 through the late 60s or early 70s
that the apparatus of the old Hollywood
system began to break down
movies continued to be made but the old
studios would by the end of the 60s or
really dissolved the studio is no longer
held contracts for dozens if not
hundreds of actors and and and and
armies of technicians and so forth to
the mass production system that had been
characteristic of Hollywood for most of
the 20th century had broken down by the
end of the 70s and what movies really
had become essentially were deals you've
got a bankable star to agree to a script
you get the screen the screenwriter to
agree to do the work you go to the money
men and you say I've got Nicholson and
I've got this screenwriter how about if
we go ahead on the movie very different
from the days in which the studio bosses
would sit down say we have to we have to
produce X number of films this year
let's decide how many westerns how many
comedies we want to make let's decide
how we want to use Barbara Stanwyck this
year that sort of thing that game is all
over so that so that from the economic
circumstances and the physical ways in
which movies are made have undergone a
transformation as well every movie
becomes a kind of major product and even
though the studio names survived beyond
the 1960s
they're just names they're just labels
now they actually no longer represent
what they had in the studio era not only
not only a particular number of films
that each studio would pump out each
year but but holdings in land and whole
major movie studios with all the with
all the supporting material and
personnel necessary to run a systematic
a systematic operation for the mass
production of movies that that that game
is over by the time the the but really
by the time the 70s begin so and if you
actually look at the physical appearance
of the actors of this period you can see
that they look less grand they look less
lower they they're literally often not
as tall Dustin Hoffman's a shrimp is
even shorter than I am when he acts with
some female stars they have to put him
on a box so he doesn't look like he's
too small they don't photograph the box
of course and there's something in not
exactly wimpish but ironic or outlaw ish
and unwholesomeness Novara nervousness
or a sense of explosive anger that might
emerge the Mickelson characters a
wonderful instance of that that might
emerge these qualities the the
instability of the idea of the hero is
part of what is emerging in these in
these in these periods and I have
another clip I want to show you that I
think can capture another part of this
it will also illustrate the new sort of
grungy type hero and movie star who
emerges in this period but it will also
tell you something else about the way in
which these transformations and
subversions
were expressed in films themselves and
this is a film this is a clip from the
end of another Robert Altman movie made
roughly around the same time it's also a
genre film and like McCabe and mrs.
Miller it's a kind of anti genre film it
uses the trappings of a traditional
genre but he turns those trappings askew
in ways that make the audience nervous
in ways that depart from not just the
standard expectations of the genre but
even the moral assumptions that are made
by the genre in in this case the moral
assumption that is that most decisively
undercut as you will see has to do with
the moral rectitude
of the hero himself and this expresses
itself all the way through many of these
stories and many of these films but it
often expresses itself with particular
clarity in the endings of films I want
you to look so watch for the kind of
actor that Elliott Gould is because he's
the store he plays the detective in this
sequence I want you to look now at the
finals really sort of the climactic
sequence the dramatic ending of an
Altman detective film a remake of a film
by the same title based on a novel by
the same title well going back into the
20s it's a film entitled The Long
Goodbye and it stars it stars Raymond
Chandler's most famous Private Eye
Private Eye Private Eye figure he had
been played this Private Eye figure had
been played in the past by some of the
some of them by a series of really sort
of tough guy Hollywood leads and in and
in Altman's version of The Long Goodbye
I think Robert Mitchum in fact a very
Hulk bulky kind of tough studly kind of
actor had had played the role at least
once previously in Altman's version of
the film Elliott Gould plays the role
and Elliott Gould is a kind of as some
of you know if you've seen his acting is
a is an actor for the for the modern age
in some ways he talks to himself a lot
the he always projects a kind of anti
heroic demeanor so so the remember we've
said also that the endings of genre
forms are often very conventionalized
think about the endings of situation
comedy as an example or the way in which
at the end of certain forms of melodrama
you will expect every yoke's you expect
certain forms of reassurance that things
will work out or have worked out right
one of the fundamental functions of the
happy ending of most genre forms in the
classic age of Hollywood was precisely
to return us to that form of reassurance
all right so here is the ending of a
fill of a detective film called The Long
Goodbye story starring Elliott Gould and
perhaps the only thing I need to do in
to introduce the scene
is to simply say that the detectives
quest has led him finally at the end of
the film to sort of solve the mystery
and he's found the man who has committed
the horrendous crimes he's been he's
been investigating through the film and
the man turns out to be a fret to have
been a friend of his someone he had
known and in fact someone someone who
had taken advantage of him and here's
the very end of the film
hi ado and Terry
Marlo
I guess if anybody's gonna track me down
would be you want drink or something no
I don't want no drink you get a kick out
at Madison I said you yeah I got a big
kick out of it so you murdered your wife
but tired
all right killed him but you can't call
it murder Wayne told her about Eileen
and me she started screaming she was
gonna tell the cops she knew I was
carrying money for Augustine she's gonna
turn me in
I hit her I didn't try to kill her I hit
her I didn't mean it I saw the
photographs boy you bashed her face in
she didn't give me any choice
you didn't have much choice huh so you
used me well that's what friends are for
I was in a gym come on have a drink I
had a dead wife $350,000 that doesn't
belong to me I had to get out it's as
simple as that
as simple as that god damn simple cops
had me legally dead
Augustine's got his money he's not
looking for me anymore I got a girl that
loves me he got more money than Silvie
and Augustine put together the hell
nobody cares
yeah nobody cares with me
bet you Marlo you'll never learn you're
a born loser yeah I even lost my cat
pretty shocking
the hero of the movie the protagonist
the gut the guy we identify with all the
way through commits cold-blooded murder
in the very he's a vigilante commits
cold-blooded murder at the end of the
film and that is the end of the film he
gets away with it I mean it's so but
there is a kind of justice done at the
end of the film in a kind of narrow way
because the murderer is caught and
punished but it's the detective and
incidentally this violates what happens
in the original novel it violates what
happens in the first film version of the
novel but think what think what happens
to John reforms not only when the hero
or the protagonist becomes grungy ironic
and anti-heroic in his behavior and and
demeanor and then when the story itself
begins to undermine the deepest
assumptions about heroism and righteous
behavior that seems to have that that's
it that seemed to justify or undergird
these endings far from a happen in a way
one could say it's a happy ending if one
wants if one has a very austere notion
of justice and almost an inhuman notion
of justice but what about this
protagonist who does his dual who does
his own vigilante justice and when when
the film first appeared I can't exempt
ossible to exaggerate the effect this
shocking ending had on being because Y
is one reason is so shocking of course
is that the generic expectations run so
totally in the opposite direction that
the most cold-blooded murder in the film
should be the character with whom you've
identified all the way through who was
supposed to be solving the crime and
bringing evil to justice that should
turn out to be evil himself in such a
shocking and brutal way undermines some
of the most basic assumptions you make
about the kind of safety that the genre
of the detective story seems to afford
to his viewers right and this is not an
isolated instance as you'll see in
tonight's film Altman does almost
exactly the same thing with the with the
Western that he does in The Long Goodbye
to the detective story and I'll return
tonight to a little bit
more to say a little bit more about the
particular ways in which McCabe and mrs.
Miller embodies this notion I've been
suggesting to you uh
embodies the the the the anti generic or
or subversive principles of the kinds of
movies that begin to emerge at the end
of the 60s and in the nineteen and in
the 1970s well I've already talked to
you about the social history of the 60s
and 70s and IIIi don't want to repeat
myself but there were some things that I
left out in my quick account earlier so
let's return briefly to remember the
sequence of presidents because of course
the sequence of presidents Kennedy to
John who is assassinated in the early
60s right already the social fabric in
the United States was frayed to the
point of breaking by the end of the 60s
those of us who lived through it will
always remember it as an astonishingly
polarized time and in the progression
from Kennedy to Johnson to Nixon there
is a social history in which that change
in the society is is of course implied
and of course it concludes in a way with
that with the terrible event of the
Watergate scandal the Watergate
investigations in which for the first
time in our history a sitting president
resigned so you can see that the social
the outward social and of course the
Watergate scandal raised doubts about
the probity and decency of the highest
officers of our government and and while
that might not seem so surprising in the
age of in the age of I have to avoid
offending some of you in the current in
our current situation where it's very
where it isn't that difficult to doubt
what we're told by our government
leaders it's important to recognize that
this not that this was a new experience
for Americans governments always lie but
there really was a sense of
disillusionment with the fundamental
structures of the society that was
emerging because of the civil rights
movement then because of the because of
the war in Vietnam where you know
and then and then also as a kind of as a
kind of icing on the cake you know in a
certain sense a kind of terrible
addition to the strengthening or
weakening the country but strengthening
this sense of polarization and
disturbances if nothing can be trusted
as if our structures are falling apart
or are endangered in some way was the
fact that the president in effect
resigned rather than face impeachment
because of his because of his behavior
in in the in the Watergate business so
that so so at the hearts of the highest
levels of government and the fundamental
structures of government were in place
and it would obviously in such a time
it's not inappropriate you would expect
the central story forms of a culture to
reflect some disturbance but why is it
not sufficient simply to urge this
argument this social history argument to
explain what happened to movies the
simplest answer is if you look at what
was on television at the same time you
can certainly see television becoming
more complex fact the late 60s and early
70s are a transforming moment for
television as well partly because that's
the moment when television consciously
realized that it has a more central
place in the society than the movies
that it had for a while already achieved
this but no one on either side of the
divide fully recognized it but by the
late 60s and early 70s American
television now knows itself to be the
central medium of consensus narrative
the society recognizes that the change
has occurred I don't mean that
legislation has passed I mean this
understanding slowly Dawn's over a
period of time right and and there was a
great sense among filmmakers of
liberation and freedom and they're not
wrong about that I mean there one might
argue that the seventies is the greatest
decade of all in the history of American
movies so many remarkable films were
made in that time and surely one of the
reasons for it was film was liberated
from the necessity to embrace what were
ultimately although very generous
principles they were still in the end
conservative principles about how a
story in a consensus medium can be told
right so but but the but the reason that
it isn't sufficient simply to the reason
that it is insufficient to it the reason
that the social history argument is
insufficient for explaining the way
movies
changed is that if you look at
television you can see a story system
that's telling stories that are more
complex and more ayran eyes and do raise
certain kinds of questions about the
social and political order that might be
thought to be disturbing and even
potentially subversive but on television
the center holds on television the
endings remain happy or at least
reassuring mostly on television some of
the very same genre forms especially
detective and cops shows are all over
the place the fables of law and order
fables of fables of injustice and the
stories that are being told on
television do not have the subversive
completely anti generic energies that
were being told on television why not
and again my answer is the movies have
been supplanted by television that
consensus role is now being played by
television and one quite I think a truly
dramatic way in which we can in which we
can recognize this development is to
talk about the differences between the
movie versions when the movie version
and the television version of another
Robert Altman text one of his
distinctive films of the 1970s the movie
mash how many of you have seen Altman's
mash only only two three
not very many it's a significant film
not as remarkable I think in its in its
full shape as the film you're going to
see tonight but but a very very
remarkable film how many of us seen the
television show mash a much larger
number but still for an American
environment a very small number I mean
especially because the show was on for
in its original run for some I'd
forgotten something like eleven years
and then was one of the longest-running
shows in American history and then of
course it was in rerun for more than a
decade in virtually every market in the
United States so there's hardly anyone
over the age of probably 15 or 20 in the
United States who hasn't seen many
episodes of mash it's so it's somewhat
surprising that a relative that only a
minority of you had seen it but but we
can take the
difference between the television
version of that program of that story
and the movie version as a kind of
emblem for this transformation that I've
been talking about and
you don't have to have seen either of
the films fully to see what I what I
have in mind the Elliott Gould the
character that you saw just a moment ago
in in the in the clip from The Long
Goodbye is one of this is one of the
central doctors in in in the movie and
the other doctor the partner doctor the
characters that are that are played by
Alan Alda and a comrade who changes over
the course of the full run of the show
in the series the Elliott Gould lays
that character in the movies and his and
his partner also varies in the in the
film but one point but his most decisive
partner is Donald Sutherland and Donald
Sutherland is another of these sort of
ironic anti-heroic actors often they
they're often actors whose diction is
odd they mumble and they swallow their
words they're sometimes literally harder
to hear than their elocution airily
superior than better adjective adverb
then then they're then they're they're
better spoken of ancestors in the
classic age of Hollywood
well in the in the movie mash made a
came out in 1970 and it was a kind of
disguised Vietnam fable it was
officially set based on a it was based
on a on a on a novel describing a mass
unit a medical unit in the Korean War
and the movie dealt with the Korean War
to ostensibly but it was clearly a
metaphor for the current war that we
were in and the doctors especially the
two central characters played by Elliott
Gould and Donald Sutherland are
unbelievably subversive figures they
take their energies more from the
counterculture than they do from any
other source they have no respect for
authority at all they're they they they
engage in forms of subversive monkey
business all the way through this the
Altman version of mash when the movie is
translated a year or two later still
while the Vietnam War is on onto a
and television in 1972 I guess and the
series's are oddly quite a lot different
it does still mobilize certain anti-war
sentiments of course and but the the the
television program which I think in in
an artistic sense is probably over the
long run of its series better than the
movie for all kinds of reasons partly
because the characters evolve and change
over time in the series in a way they
could not in the movie but the most
decisive thing about it is that the
movie we that the television series
retains some of the qualities it retains
some of the qualities that we associate
with with an anti shun reform it there
are subversive implications in it for
sure but the center holds in the
television version why that when I say
the center holds what I mean is that
there remains in the film our respect
for the larger structures of authority
and order in a society however antic and
subversive the doctors might behave in
any particular instance the the the
literal behavior of the characters is
often less grungy and doesn't flirt with
pornography in the movie on the
television show as it does in the in the
movie I don't mean that the movie is
pornographic but it's much more overt
about sexual matters than the more than
the television series is and one of the
best ways one can see the contrast is to
contrast an actor like Alan Alda with an
actor like Elliott Gould there's
something dark and grungy and self
reflective so self-aware about about
Elliott Gould that one doesn't feel
about although Aldous much easier in his
skin than Elliott Gould it one feels
about Elliott Gould as about many of the
actors that emerge as dominant stars in
the 70s and Beyond is that they're
afflicted by a kind of cosmic anxiety
that they're that they're figured that
they're anxious figures that they're
figures of damage in some way the Warren
Beatty is such an actor in many ways
he's good he's the star of tonight's
film McCabe and mrs. Miller there's a
particularly wonderful film of the 1970s
that I also want to mention to you after
I complete my discourse about
so these two versions of mash then sort
of dramatized for us not that television
becomes a especially by 1970 is is
simply a reactionary medium that just
repeats what the ruling class in the
United States wants it to say it's a
much more complicated medium than that
but it is a consensus medium it
understands that it has or it it
operates according to certain unwritten
rules that the society as a whole has
accepted and one of those rules is that
in a consensus medium you can raise all
Comeau belies all kinds of doubts and
dubia teas and and and and ironic
perspectives on the larger culture or on
the central values of the culture but
you can't repudiate them completely you
can't let people come out of a consensus
medium thinking that the society is
totally corrupt that there's no hope for
the world it's big consensus systems
won't allow it allow that they have a
kind of aesthetic and political
conservatism built into them right and
the movie mash shows how free it is of
those consensus values and the
television show mash on the contrary
demonstrates how much pressure a
particular genre may receive and still
remain in some sense a consensus a
consensus form and in fact I mean it
seems to me there are many arguments to
be made for the idea that meant that
mash is one of the most distinctive
artistic achievements of American
television that it that it that it
represents a culmination in some sense
of series traditions that go back almost
thirty years by the time mash appears
well but but that what gives it its real
authority and power is that it
incorporates into itself a subject
matter that before the mid 60s anyway
had never been on television before so
it's not that the television that
appears in the late 60s and early 70s is
trivial or foolish it's just that it is
constrained by these consensus
principles that no longer constrain that
no longer constrained the American movie
and when we look at tonight's film
you'll see very decisive examples of
this and I'm excited about how clearly
McCabe and mrs. Miller
will crystallize the kinds of things
I've been saying to you this afternoon
now I I also want to mention this other
example a film I meant to mention
earlier when I was going through these
motions about the way in which we have
new different kinds of directors
different kinds of actors different
kinds of endings right which means that
the style of the movies is often
different as well the visual texture of
the film is that they favor jump cuts
and discontinuity tricks much more than
the classic Hollywood movie does and the
the film I wanted to tell you about is a
film I meant to mention it earlier and
I'll conclude today's lecture with a
sort of another example like the
examples I've given so far in which what
we get is a profoundly subversive film
whose presence would have been
impossible five years earlier when the
movie or ten years earlier when the
movies were still performing their
consensus function in American society
and the film I'm thinking about is a
film by the director Alan J Pakula some
people call him Alan peculiar called the
parallax of you any of you seen the
parallax view it's one of them it's one
of the great films of this early pair of
this early seventies period and it's a
it's a conspiracy fantasy film it's a
fill up and it it's some Warren Beatty
plays the central character in the film
has a drunk and in fact the fact that
he's a drunkard and a radically
imperfect person is also characteristic
of the kinds of heroes that a
protagonist that we begin to see in the
70s and Beyond radically imperfect
protagonists begin to become much more
than norm in Hollywood in American
movies after the Hollywood system has
declined well in this film Warren Beatty
plays a recovered alcoholic journalist
who has been fired from a series of
important jobs and is now working for a
minor newspaper in Seattle Washington
his name is Freddie fr a idy I think of
millions F rdy but it's supposed to echo
afraid fraidy afraid he's like a
fraidy-cat
is you're supposed to sort of partly
feel in the film and with the help of a
newspaper editor he works for he falls
upon or stumbles upon what turns out to
be a vast political conspiracy he's
actually present in the beginning of the
film at what looks like a random killing
of a political candidate begins to
investigate he discovers in fact that
there was probably a conspiracy
the guy was assassin the candidate was
assassinated and then he added he goes
undercover and he begins he under he
engages in a long investigation the
shape of the film and the energies of
the film are very like dozens of films
we've seen earlier especially during the
Hollywood era in which a lone hero
discovering terrible facts that are
going that are dangerous to his
community or his society shows the
courage and the fortitude and and the
resilience and the focus to follow
through and solve the mystery and then
save the world at the end in the most
elaborate versions of this fantasy
what's at stake is the fate of the world
or the fate of a society in smaller
versions it might be something somewhat
less but and that's what it turns out
here he penetrates into this conspiracy
and there are allusions and references
that make you especially at the end of
the film associate the conspiracy with
the with the Kennedy assassination there
there is in the in the film then a kind
of ongoing process in which the full
nature of the conspiracy begins to
emerge and in fact it is an unbelievable
I mean if you if you actually saw the
world in that way you probably couldn't
even get a job in the White House I'm
sorry but it's it's a it's really an
unbelievably conspiratorial film in
which it turns out that that there are
that there is a sort of network of
corporate controllers who are sort of in
effect taking over the government of the
United States and they have unbelievable
power and nobody knows about any way
that this detective has finally
uncovered the plot and we watch him do
it and as the film comes to its
conclusion what do we expect will happen
what's the normal expectation in such a
film that that his revelations will save
the day right well in the very final
sequences of this film we
see what looks like a kind of Revelation
scene in which our character fraidy is a
he's in a convention hall where they're
about to hold a political nominating
convention in fact it's very resonant
because the conspiracy the conspirators
are trying to contrive to control that
space as well and essentially he starts
chasing a bad guy being chased by a bad
guy and without without going into any
detail I'll spoil the film for you
although in a way I must
guess what happens our hero was killed
at the end just at the moment and and
the film ends with the idea that the
conspiracy is in force that that there's
been no change so it's an unbelievably
disturbing it would have been a
disturbing film even if it had ended
with the requisite happy ending and the
reassuring ending but but because it and
how many in how many films does the
great hero the character you've been
following all the way through who's
supposed to be who's supposed to be the
one in which you've invested all your
sympathy and respect and how many films
does this guy get blown away at the end
but it's a mark of how subversive how
turbulent morally turbulent and
uncertain and also much and how
politically and and and and morally
engaged movies had become by the early
seventies that such an ending was
possible so the parallax view seems to
be it's another kind of anti genre in a
way it's like a spy film in which they
lone here like in in some ways it's like
one of those Hitchcock romantic
thrillers in which Cary Grant and a
beautiful woman traveled through
beautiful locales and finally even
though they look as if they're in great
danger when the day are able to are able
to marry at the end and also
incidentally have saved the United
States government right the film fits
that kind of category but it explodes
all of our expectations about the
characters and about the atmosphere of
such of such and of such films and in
that sense the parallax view like McCabe
and mrs. Miller like Altman's film ash
like his film Nashville like the films
of Martin's course
see that appear mean streets his first
film and maybe his greatest film appears
in this period as well giving you a much
grungier more disturbed more damaged
more hopeless view of urban violence
than any film before it had done again
mobilizing the genres of the gangster
film and the urban crime film but
mobilizing them in a way that leaves the
viewer unsettled and disturbed
so the 70s is an astonishing a
remarkable moment in the history of
American film it's remarkable not only
because films became more courageous and
more dangerous in the thematic and moral
sense but also because in the core
because it was an era in which that
happened in consequence of the fact that
the movies had surrendered their central
place in American society to this new
medium of television I'll talk about
some of these matters tonight in a much
more concrete way by looking closely at
McCabe and mrs. Miller
you